Welcome to this
prep lecture
for OMM lab number 23,
counterstrain
of the shoulder
and reviewing material
covering all
foundation's thoracic
region material.
This includes
both diagnosis
and treatment.
Here are today's
session objectives.
You will be learning
and practicing seven
counterstrain point
locations and their
respective treatments.
You will also be reviewing
the material on upper
extremity as shown
here, as well as for
the thoracic region.
You have already been
introduced to this
material before, so I
have simply reposted it
here with some minimal
revisions in the
following slides to
tailor it for this
particular lab, but it
is essentially the same
information, so please
take a moment to review
this and apply it
during this lab. Here
again are additional
pointers for this lab.
You had this in lab
17. I removed the
statement regarding
the lower extremities
because we're dealing with
the upper extremities,
but it is otherwise
the same material.
Aim to really sense
the soft tissue texture
and any changes as
you set up the patient
into the mobile point
and as you monitor
the mobile point during
the course of treatment
in other words with
practice you should
be able to not only
feel tissue texture
changes but make a
prediction regarding how
much it has improved
and therefore a sense
of how much reduction
in tenderness you can
expect and of course
with counter strain
since you will be
asking the patient for a
tenderness rating, you
can easily correlate
what you feel with
what you actually get
from the patient in
terms of their response.
Practice makes better
and perhaps even
perfect. So
hopefully you feel by
this point that you
are moving along in
terms of your
counterstrain skills.
So now we move on to the
counterstrain
points themselves.
There are a total
of seven points
that you will
learn for this lab.
It's helpful
to think of the
location of these
points and the
corresponding
treatment positions.
The first two points here
are the pectoralis minor
and the subscapularis.
Note how each
of these points are
in the region of
the myotendinous
region of the muscle.
For the pectoralis minor,
it's understandable
how one would
palpate anteriorly on
the upper anterior chest
wall near the coracore
process to find this
particular point
for the subscapularis
it is important to
locate it on the
undersurface meaning on the
anterior aspect of the
scapula the scapula
as you know is on the
posterior aspect of
the body and therefore
its anterior aspect
will still seem to be
located posteriorly
In the diagram,
excuse me, in the
picture below, we
can see how the
doctor's palpating
finger is in
the posterior
axillary fold region.
However, to truly
find this point, one
should attempt to
locate the bony
lateral edge of the
scapula first and then
move medial to
that in order to
contact a little bit
of its undersurface.
This area can be
quite tender, so it's
important for you to
inform your partner
and of course your
future patients that
you will be looking
for this point
and to keep them
relaxed and to approach
slowly and communicate
with the patient
so that if your
pressure is too strong
you can lighten your
contact pressure.
The next two anterior
shoulder constraint
points are for the
short head of the
biceps and long head
of the biceps. Note
that both of these
points are located
on a tendon of the
respective structure.
For the short
head of the biceps
shown on the left,
it is close to its
origin from the
core cord process.
Finding the core cord
process is a useful
first step to locate
this point reliably.
The core cord process is
relatively superficial,
but it can still be
hard to find in some
patients depending on
the amount of overlying
soft tissue so a
reliable method that I
have found useful is
to first locate the
lateral part of the
clavicle and go slightly
inferior and from this
location if you don't
already find it you
locate the pectodeltoid
groove meaning the
muscular groove formed
by the pectoralis major
intersecting with or
meeting up with the
anterior deltoid muscle
The corcord
process is either
found at the groove
or more often,
slightly lateral
to the groove.
One has to press
with sufficient
pressure to locate
the corcord process,
and once you find
it, go slightly
inferior to locate
the constrain point.
For the longhead of
the biceps, or the
tendon specifically,
one would locate
its location in the
bicipital groove of
the anterior aspect
of the humeral head.
it has a distinctive
texture to it it's
smooth and relatively
thin not not not very
thin but relatively
thin and has a movement
that you can appreciate
if you have the
patient contract and
relax biceps muscle
another way is to have
the patient externally
and internally rotate
the shoulder slightly
while you palpate
over the humeral head
and feel the rolling
motion of the tendon.
Both of the treatment
positions are similar
with the patient
being supine and a
position controlling
at the patient's elbow.
Note for the short
head of the biceps, due
to its more medial
location, shoulder
adduction is incorporated
as part of the
treatment position,
whereas for the long head
of the biceps, shoulder
abduction is used.
Next, we turn to the
first two posterior
counterstrain points
for the shoulder.
On the left, we have
the supraspinatus
counterstrain point,
which is shown
in the middle portion
of the muscle. On
the right, we see
the levator scapula
counterstrain point,
with the point
identified at the distal
end of the muscle.
keep in mind that
the levator scapula
inserts into the superior
medial portion of
the scapula this
point of its insertion
will become important
as I discuss it further
in a moment so for
the supraspinatus
counterstring point
the patient is treated
in the supine position
with the physician
controlling at the
elbow but depending
on the patient's elbow
size it may be easier
to actually control
it at the forearm.
The shoulder is abducted
and the patient's
forearm is aiming
towards the
patient's head,
meaning in a vertically
oriented position
relative to the patient.
This resembles a little
bit the Statue of
Liberty where the
shoulder is abducted and
the forearm is aiming
towards the patient's
head. It's not a
perfect resemblance.
The full Statue of
Liberty position involves
a more shoulder
abduction and the elbow
is extended not flex
as shown here so
please do not replicate
the full statue of
liberty position but
unofficially if you can
think of this as the
statue of liberty
position it will
hopefully facilitate your
ability to remember
and treat the patient
the key of course is
to use the tenderness
scale and fine-tune
in order to get to
as close to a 0 or
ideally to a 0 over 10.
Now we turn to the
levator scapula point.
The treatment position
involves the patient
being prone and the
physician holding the
patient's distal forearm
and as part of the
treatment traction is
used. Why traction?
Well this takes us
back to how the levator
scapula inserts into
the scapula. If you
imagine for a moment
the levator scapular
contracting it will
elevate the scapula hence
the term levator scapula
but it will actually
also introduce a
degree of rotation of
the scapula so in
counter strain of course
the patient doesn't
contract so if it is the
doctor that induces
the rotation by virtue
of applying traction
to the patient's arm
this will have a
similar effect in other
words the physician by
exerting traction as
part of the technique
will actually in this
instance introduce
clockwise rotation of
the right scapula and
therefore introduce
relaxation some
shortening of that muscle
creating ease of that
muscle in order to promote
relaxation of that
counter strain point
The last posterior
points for the slab
are for the rhomboid
major and minor.
Note that these points
are located near the
attachment to the
medial edge of the
scapula, and depending
on the severity and
exact location, you
may have to use more or
less shoulder extension
and adduction.
Because the patient is
facing down, meaning
they're prone, it's
important for you to pay
attention to any
physical clues that they
are not tolerating
your technique such as
if they make any
sounds of course or if
they tighten up so make
sure again that you
pay attention and
monitor the point and of
course use the
tenderness scale here i
would like to share
some final tips for you
to learn to perfect
counter strain the most
important i think is
to have a practice
method for how to perform
the various points
it's very easy to get
lost in the details
of any particular
technique and just as I
have shown in the
previous slides it's good
to organize them in
terms of their location
as well as the general
treatment position
so my first tip is for
you to visualize the
final treatment position
and therefore get
a good understanding
of the basic position
Number two is think
of all the steps of
counterstrain in a
logical fashion. Just as
you would not want
to address or fix
something that isn't
broken when you are
assigned a counterstrain
point, for example,
to perform the
technique on, you should
always start by
pressing on the point
in order to see if
it's tender. In other
words, see if it
is an active point.
And this might seem
obvious, but when
you are assigning
a point, don't
automatically assume
that it's positive.
Go through the step
of checking for
any tenderness. This
would, of course,
also allow you to
feel any tissue
texture change
along the way.
In other words,
make a prediction of
whether you think
it would even be
tender prior to even
asking the patient.
number three smoothly
set up and sequence
through all the points
so for example if you
were to treat the
pectoralis minor counter
strain point as the
first point and then
transition to the
biceps tender points the
medial excuse me the
short head of the biceps
and then a long head
of the biceps then
you would hopefully
realize that they are
all performed in a supine
position and therefore
you can move from one
treatment position
to another to another
and this allows you
efficiency in how
you practice so in a
relatively short period
of time if you are
worried just with setting
up the final treatment
position you can run
through the sequence
a number of times to
get extra practice
and lastly take your
time to feel your body
position in other
words not just how the
patient is position
but how you are holding
them in place how does
it feel or how are
you comfortable what
do your arms feel like
what do your hands
feel like therefore you
get to in a sense own
the technique not just
in your mind but in
your body so you are
building muscle memory
so taking a moment to
reflect on that as
you're performing the
technique will allow
you to absorb that sense
in your own bodies and
make performing the
technique that much
easier going forward.
I have listed here
the various topics for
you to review for
both diagnosis and
treatment. These are for
the ACSC and glenohumeral
joints as well as
for thoracic spine.
This material
is testable on
written and
practical exams.
Thank you for your
attention. The shoulder
is a very important
region and many
patients come in with
shoulder complaints.
Symptoms related to the
shoulder can include
the neck, the head,
the upper back, as
well as the upper
extremities. So please
perform a good history
and physical examination
and incorporate the
osteopathic structural
examination which
includes the use of
counterstrain points
into your evaluation.
I hope you enjoy
this lab. Thank you.